We've lifted the lid on
the Android Studio Box
and pulled out Instant Run, a
fast and shiny new emulator,
a new GPU profiler and
all the new features
and improvements of IntelliJ 15.
I'm Reto Meier.
It's Android Tool Time time,
and this is Android Studio 2.0.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Instant Run is a
new feature that,
once enabled, lets you build
and deploy incremental changes
to your app within
a few seconds,
dramatically improving the speed
of your test and debug cycles.
Once you have your app up and
running, hitting Instant Run
after making code changes such
as changing this chessboard
from 2D to 3D and modifying the
size and color of the pieces,
will perform a hot swap,
sending only the changed code
to your app.
The affected methods
are overridden,
and your code changes
are applied in real time
within the running app instance.
Hot swapping works by injecting
code where you make changes.
Your app isn't restarted,
so memory allocations
remain unchanged, meaning class
initializes won't be re-run
and static variables
aren't initialized.
Existing instances
and constructs
like Fields and Singletons
are left untouched.
Changing resources, such
as editing colors, strings,
or even layouts will send
the modified resources
file to the running app.
And you will be able to
see it when the activity is
restarted-- called
a warm swap, which
will do for you automatically if
we detect that it's necessary.
Some changes such as modifying
your manifest or changing
layout IDs currently
trigger a full build.
Exactly which changes
will cause a full rebuild
versus a cold or warm swap will
change as Instant Run improves
and evolves.
So rather than listing
them here in detail
and having this video
become quickly outdated,
you can find the
details in the Docs.
Instant Run works
with all emulators
in every recent physical device.
In fact, on every
platform version
all the way back to
Ice Cream Sandwich.
Not content with Instant
Run, Android Studio 2.0
also improves each step of the
full build and deploy process.
So even full builds happen more
than 2 and 1/2 times faster.
The first time you
hit Run or Debug
for your code or each
time you do a clean build,
your code is compiled and
converted to dex files,
is optionally shrunk, optimized,
and obfuscated with Proguard
and has its classes
and resources
packaged all before it's
uploaded to the device
and installed.
Android Studio 2.0 has
improved each of these steps,
starting with dx.
We have reduced time
here by over half,
primarily through improving
the dx merger algorithm.
Now that merging dex dependency
modules is lightning fast,
we gain significant gains
from pre-dexing them and not
re-dexing them if
they haven't changed.
So if your project
has a lot of modules,
you'll see significant
gains here.
We've also modified dx so
that it now runs in process,
and you can specify
running up to four dx
instances in parallel.
This has significant advantages,
as we no longer start a new VM
for each dx instance, keeping
the GIT more opportunity
to optimize code and removing
the overhead of starting
and running multiple
parallel VM instances.
If you're using Proguard,
it creates a single job
that effectively disables
the pre-dexing advantages
that we just gained.
So we developed a new shrinker
to use in debug builds.
It doesn't replace
Proguard, it just
replaces it's shrinking
functionality.
So you'll still need to run
Proguard on release builds
to optimize and
obfuscate your code.
But for debugging the
shrinker is much faster
by including some
incremental support
and critically by not
re-dexing dependencies.
To improve AAPT packaging
times on full builds,
we now ask you to
select a deploy target
before your app is
built. We'll check
what resources are required
for that particular device.
For example, initially
we'll only package and push
the appropriate image
resource resolutions.
And future Android
Studio releases
will expand that to include
resources such as ABIs Legacy
MultiDex.
To improve deploy times,
we improved the ADB
push-pull protocol,
making it very fast
to deploy to an emulator, which
seems like a really good reason
to improve the emulator UX
and make it really, really
ridiculously fast.
In fact, running
the new emulator
on typical dev
hardware is faster than
using a physical Android device.
To achieve this
without an SMP support
to take advantage of host
multi-core architecture
and optimize GPU, IO,
and CPU performance.
At the same time, we completely
rebuilt the emulator UI.
It now includes a
toolbar to enable actions
like screen rotation
and screen shots
and support for deploying
APKs through drag and drop.
You can rescale the emulator
frame by dragging a corner,
modify device hardware
changes like GPS,
cellular network
conditions, battery state,
and incoming phone
calls or texts.
We've also made it easier
to keep up to date.
The IDE will prompt you
when there's a new emulator
available for you to download.
If you're building something
graphics intensive,
like a game, you can take
advantage of our new GPU
profiler and debugger.
It lets you record and replay
the entire GPU stream frame
by frame, allowing
you to inspect the GPU
state at each stage
and help you understand
what caused each specific
rendering outcome.
You can select an
individual frame
by either the top bar or
the GPU Commands panel.
Once you select a frame,
the frame buffer window
will update to show
that frame's contents.
You can also see and inspect
each individual command and GL
call that was used.
You can also use the GPU State
window or the Textures tab
to explore GPU state at the time
of your selected frame or draw
calls.
Android Studio 2.0 is
built on IntelliJ 15, which
offers improved stability
and a number of new features,
including improvements to
the built-in integrations
with version control
systems, such as support
for rebase on GIT and cool new
features like Find in Path,
and Distraction-Free Mode.
There's also a unified
user interface for testing
that includes a Test Run a Tool
window, In-line Statistics,
and a Test Result History.
We've built on top of
those test improvements,
allowing you to have both
Android and unit tests
source sets active
while you develop,
enabling refactorings
across those source sets.
We've also worked closely
with Google Search
to make it easier to create
deep links within your app,
including static
code inspections
to check that your links
are correctly configured
and real time testing to
confirm Google can index
and render your app
pages correctly.
In future episodes
of Android Tool Time,
we'll dive deeper into
these and other new features
from Android Studio.
So subscribe to Android
Developers on YouTube,
and check out the Android
Tool Time playlist.
And remember, if you've been
taking your breaks based
on building and
deploying your app,
you may want to start setting
alarms to remind you to eat
and drink at regular intervals.
That's Android Studio 2.0,
and this was Android Tool Time
time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]